le 6 octobre 2019
le parti islamo-conservateur ennahda
emmenés par rached ghanouchi remporté
les élections législatives devant le
parti politique au coeur de la tunisie
de nabil karoui patron d'un groupe de
médias et de publicité
le scrutin qui avait débuté quelques
semaines après la présidentielle
remportée par rail sayed ovni de la
scène politique tunisienne avait connu
une faible participation
- d'un tunisien sur deux s'étaient alors
déplacés aux urnes
c'est dans ce contexte marqué par une
forte abstention qu'elias par fars qui
n'a obtenu que 0 34% des voix aux
dernières élections présidentielles est
désigné après plusieurs mois de
tractations chef du gouvernement par le
président reyes sayyed mais cinq mois
plus tard le 15 juillet 2020 sous la
pression du parti dominant ennahda qui a
mis en avant des soupçons de corruption
pesant sur lui
elyes ben arfa est contrainte de déposer
sa démission au président rayess sayyed
il signe au passage le plus court mandat
depuis la révolution de 2011
en attendant un successeur il garde ses
fonctions et affirme récemment dans une
interview accordée à express fm qu'on
lui aurait proposé de rester plus
longtemps à la tête du gouvernement
sous certaines conditions on m'a proposé
un accord pour continuer à gouverner
mais je n'ai pas cédé à peine cinq mois
après des négociations difficiles pour
mettre en place un gouvernement
le départ forcé du premier ministre
ouvre la voie à de nouvelles
négociations qui s'annoncent compliquées
le président est placée au centre du jeu
politique et doit élire une personne
compétente pour remplacer eliès par fars
après consultations avec les partis
politiques la coalition et les groupes
parlementaires qui entretiennent entre
eux des liens très conflictuelle c'est
une fuite en avant avec le risque que
ces surenchères politiciennes accentue
les tensions sociales au moment où on
nous annonce une croissance en recul de
7% et d'importantes pertes d'emplois
le pays semble s'enfoncer de plus en
plus dans une instabilité politique
alors que la rentrée et toutes les
retombées économiques liées à la crise
du coronavirus et au confinement
approche à grands pas hier deux noms ont
été largement
désignés par les partis politiques
siégeant au gouvernement pour succéder à
eliès par fars fadhel abdelkéfi ancien
ministre du développement et de
l'investissement et ryan turki analystes
financiers et fondateur de plusieurs
sociétés et institutions dans le domaine
de créances financière le président ier
sayed devrait annoncer aujourd'hui le
nom du prochain chef du gouvernement
la personne désignée aura un mois pour
former son gouvernement qui devra
ensuite obtenir la confiance du
parlement à la majorité absolue d'ici
septembre faute de quoi
l'assemblée sera dissoute et de
nouvelles élections législatives seront
organisées